[MUSIC PLAYING]
KIR TITIEVSKY: My name is Kir.
I am a product manager
in Google Cloud.
I work on Cloud Pub/Sub.
That means I get to
talk to a lot of data
engineers across the world,
both users of Cloud Pub/Sub
and Kafka, and things like
Dataflow and BigQuery.
So we'll-- today's session will
be about using those tools.
Now there are a
couple things that
are interesting about Kir--
that is, me-- in this context.
One is, as I said, I get to
work on Cloud Pub/Sub, which
is a very large distributed
service, that we try to run
with very good availability.
And we've learned a few things
about using real time streaming
data to help us do that.
So I will share some
of that experience
to help motivate why
Stream Analytics is
important to answer the
question why this matters.
The second reason
is that, as I said,
I'm lucky enough to have
it as part of my job
to speak to a lot of
data engineering teams.
And so I've learned quite a
bit over my last few years
doing that.
So I'm grateful for that.
And I've learned that it's
a pretty interesting time
in the industry with a
lot of interesting people.
So I'm going to take just a
few seconds out of this talk
to say if there is somebody
you don't know next to you,
they're probably an
interesting data engineer.
Say hello.
You don't have to if
you're uncomfortable.
But I'll awkwardly stand
here for 10 seconds.
But really, shake--
shake the hand--
hey.
[LAUGHTER]
All right--
All right, I hope you
met another person.
And after this talk, you
can ask them what they do.
And so what I'll do is I'll
stop with the corny jokes,
and I'll try to answer a couple
of questions, which is really
one question-- why do we
care about Stream Analytics?
And why do we need
fresh data, which
is really what this is about?
And then I'll hand this off
to a person who actually
has had quite a bit of success
with building Stream Analytics
systems on GCP.
That's Simon Forman, who is
the head of behavioral data
engineering at ITV.
That's one of England's
premier TV networks.
So he'll tell you a
lot more about that.
So let's get into it.
Stream Analytics is about
moving from dealing with files--
to give you a figure,
10 megabytes plus--
to dealing with one
kilobyte at a time.
As soon as a thing
happens, you process it.
And that requires a bit
of a shift in thinking,
a new kind of technology.
You need new storage technology.
You need new
processing technology.
And you need a new way
to access your data.
So on the storage, again,
we've had tremendous amount
of success with technologies for
handling blobs-- large files.
Now you need things like
Cloud Pub/Sub and Apache Kafka
that are great at accepting
appends and persisting them
on disk at one
kilobyte at a time.
There are no more files.
They're kind of infinite, right?
So you need to be able
to deal with that.
And you need to be able to let
multiple distributed clients
tail these files without
introducing latency.
So that's a new kind
of storage technology.
On the processing
side, you have now jobs
that don't just come up,
process a file, and shut down.
You have jobs that run for not
hours, but days, and months,
and sometimes years.
So you need something that's
stable enough to do this.
You need something that can
recover and heal itself when
it's not having a good time.
And you need something
that is going
to be able to help you deal
with data that is unbounded.
There are no files.
There's no end to file.
So how do you know when
you've gotten everything?
It turns out that it's
not a trivial problem.
So tools like Dataflow
Apache Spark and Flink
start solving that.
And finally, once you've
done all of this--
you've done the work
of persisting the data
and processing it in let's say
100 milliseconds or a second.
You need a storage
and access system
or a database that is not
going to take all that away.
And we talk about
BigQuery streaming API
here, which allows you to
get to your data instantly.
So now, why do you
care to make this shift
in your organization?
There's been a lot of success
just-- many operations team
that, in fact, will
tell you, well,
we're very happy just
to have our data.
It doesn't matter
that it's fresh.
that it's streaming.
Like, if you give me my
data within an hour of it
being generated, I'm great.
Why do you care?
There are many
reasons to do this.
And I'll try to focus
on a couple that often
get overlooked, partly because
they are a little bit too
close--
they seem obvious-- and
partly because, in some ways,
measuring quality service and
sort of saying ops is a bit
too--
measuring quality of
service has historically
been rather difficult. So
we've kind of glossed over it.
So again, the two reasons to
care about Stream Analytics
is that you need fresh data
on your quality of service.
When things go
wrong with whatever
it is that your
company does, you
should know about it not in an
hour-- you should know about it
now, in 10 seconds, in a
minute, but not an hour.
And when you do
know about this, you
need your operations teams,
your SRE team, your content
operations, your
finance operations
to have all of the
supporting data
to resolve the problem
right there and then.
So you need fresh data
on quality of service
and fresh data on operations.
So yes, there is some feature
deep in your backlog that's
about flying cars,
and recommendations,
and instant optimization
of everything,
and A/B testing that
is all wonderful.
But Stream Analytics
is about something
much more basic than that.
It's quality of service.
So I'll try to not--
I'll try to give you a
more concrete example based
on something that I know and
sort of experienced firsthand,
which is how we think
about quality of service
at Cloud Pub/Sub in GCP.
And that's generally
representative of how
other services
are run at Google.
So when we launched
a few years back,
we started with a single SLA--
service level agreement--
that was our promise
to our customers, which was
that when your front ends were
ready to hand us off a piece
of data, an event, a log entry,
we would accept it
with high likelihood.
We had 4 1/2 nines of
availability, I think,
when we started.
And so that was our SLA.
And behind it, there was an
SLO, a service level objective,
which is a metric that
was measured in real time.
And someone's pager
was connected to it.
So if all of a sudden you
couldn't publish your data--
your front end set had
accumulated in their memory
and were on their
way to crashing,
someone's pager was going
off and we would fix it.
And then we had a bunch
of low volume probers
that would exercise the system--
sort of different paths
through the system
using synthetic traffic.
Moving on from
there, we've designed
a brilliant alerting
system which
was to use our users
as a way to get us data
when things were going wrong.
So something would go wrong
with your application.
Let's say you couldn't create
a topic or get your data.
You would submit a ticket
to our support system.
It would get triaged by
front line support personnel,
get escalated to
a specialist, get
escalated to the
engineering team,
and then finally, just short
hours, weeks, days, or weeks
later, the issue would be fixed.
This is, of course, sort of--
I'm being facetious here.
This was a horrible system.
Even that was a step
up for many users.
Because oftentimes these systems
within individual organizations
are run by much smaller teams.
But certainly, using our
users as an alerting system
or taking hours to
weeks to resolve
issues that went
beyond our primary SLA
was really no way to live.
And so we've changed
things a bit.
And we said, OK,
let's understand
our quality of service, actually
the way our users actually
perceive it.
And at the end of
this exercise--
rather sort of at the
stage where we are now,
we went from one primary
user facing SLA or an SLO
backing it to 234
SLOs that are all
connected to someone's pager.
And so we said, our
promise to the world
is really not that you
can publish a message.
It's not uptime.
It's our entire API.
We publish our API
as a [INAUDIBLE]..
You can see it.
And all of it is a promise.
So we want to make sure that
the whole thing is working.
So we had to look
at availability
across all operations
in real time.
We had to look at not just
the success rate but also
the latency of operations.
We wanted to make sure we
understood when things were not
going right in that respect.
Looking deeper at this,
we had to realize that it
wasn't just about the API.
Our promise to the world
went beyond the API.
It wasn't that you could
publish your message
and receive a message.
It was that the message would
be delivered from a publisher
to every single subscriber.
It turns out that's
not an API method.
That's something synthetic
you have to compute
by joining multiple API calls.
So we started
looking at end to end
latency of message delivery.
And then finally, we had
to make all of this data
available so that we could
respond to issues with any
of these SLOs within minutes
and hopefully get to them
before any of our customers
would have to submit a ticket.
So this is what it
looks like today.
I've put some x's there.
You can ask me what
the actual numbers are.
Just as an example, Publish--
I'm giving you an example
of a Publish operations,
but we have the same
thing for others.
So we look at the overall
method availability.
We have to normalize
it somehow so
that successful traffic
from really large customers
doesn't obscure terrible
problems from small volume
customers.
We have to look at it in
each individual region.
So here, there's US West.
But we have to have it in every
single region where GCP runs.
And finally, we have to look
at these latency numbers.
And then we repeat this
for every other operation.
I've talked about end
to end latency, right?
We had to measure that-- also
not a straightforward thing
to do.
We had to look at latency
within each individual region.
We also make a
rather unique promise
to the world, which is
that we will deliver
your message to wherever your
clients are from wherever
they were published.
So we're a global service.
So we had to have
operations-- we have to have
metrics per continent pair.
And then finally, we
had to have a few SLOs
for administrative operations.
They're interesting
only in that there
are different
expectations around them.
So SLOs are different.
So having gone
through this exercise,
we realized that--
you know, these
are metrics from this year.
And I'm very happy with those.
They weren't like
this when we started.
The color was red
when we started.
And that was the primary--
sort of the primary
impact of this exercise
was to realize that things
are not well and fixing it.
So this is a true humble
brag in that this is a brag.
I'm very excited that we
measure so many things,
and we're great at them.
But this is also a pretty
humbling experience.
Because until we did
this, it turned out
that there were 233 dimensions
of our customer experience
that we had no idea about until
somebody submitted a ticket.
So I bet that's happening
in your organization.
And I think that
that, in my mind,
gets at the core of why Stream
Analytics and fresh data
is important.
It's just quality of service.
I'll try to answer
one more question
before I hand this off to Simon
to talk about how you actually
do these things which is--
fine, metrics are great.
SLOs are great.
Everybody read the SRE book--
yes?
Yes, I'm seeing nodding heads.
Great, metrics are great.
But why do you need
to build new things?
Don't we have monitoring
tools like Stackdriver
for operations metrics and
Google Analytics for content
metrics?
Those work.
The answer is, of
course, they do.
And you should use them
for everything you can.
But I bet you there is
something about your company
that is unique.
You are in business
because you do
something that is different from
what everybody else is doing.
And so there's going to
be that one metric that
is absolutely core to what
your business is that you're
going to need to
compute by yourself
and figure out how to measure.
So in the example of Pub/Sub,
it seemed like we kind of
had it all under control.
There was just an API.
And you know what an
API success rate is.
But then you get until these
things are like, OK, well,
the API is running
in different regions.
And there are
customer sizes that
vary by multiple
orders of magnitude.
How do you normalize them?
How do you make sure that
every customer is happy?
That's not a standard
sort of thing.
That's a value judgment you
have to make for your business.
And then you get into things
like end to end latency, right?
Again, the reason I took
you through that whole story
is to just give you a sense of
the depth you can start getting
at when you start pushing at
the definition of your promise
to the world.
And so with end to
end latency, the thing
that was kind of not
obvious at first,
we started and said, all
right, end to end latency
is about a difference
between two timestamps.
Timestamp a message
when it comes.
And then when somebody
says give me a message,
you compute the difference.
And it made a real value.
Amazing-- not very
interesting, though.
It turns out that that's
not the whole story.
Because what we promise
is that if you give us
enough opportunities to deliver
a message, we will do that.
But if you're not,
we can't be-- we
can't have our pagers ringing.
That's not our promise.
And so as it turns
out the reasons
why we may not sometimes
be able to send you
a message has to do with
your client's state.
So sometimes clients
are under-provisioned.
Maybe you have
messages that require
two machines to process, but
you only have one machine.
Or you have a spike
or something, right?
You don't give us enough
opportunities to deliver.
Messages pile up.
Latency goes up.
It's not a systems problem.
It's not us breaking a promise.
Sometimes there are
bugs in clients.
You grab-- as a client,
you get a message.
You process it.
And then you crash
before acknowledging,
or for Kafka people, before
committing the offset.
We deliver the message to you.
We're doing everything
right, right?
But the timestamp grows.
Sometimes users choose
not to consume messages
with low latency.
And so all of a sudden, what
this means is that in order
to compute that
difference of timestamps
you need to join it with some
kind of stream of understanding
of what your clients are doing
for each individual client
and say, well, is this client
in a healthy state or not?
And if it is, then you can
say, OK, we trust this metric.
So this simple
timestamp difference
becomes a complicated thing.
And this is a thing that is
absolutely at the core of what
we do as a service.
So I hope that gives you a sense
for why Stream Analytics is
important to something very
basic in your business--
again, not the thing deep in
the backlog, although that
will come, I'm sure.
And I hope it gives you some
ideas for what you might
compute if you had the tools.
Now I will stop at this.
And I will ask Simon
Forman up on stage
to tell you about his
journey at ITV in doing this.
[APPLAUSE]
SIMON FORMAN: Thanks Kir.
Hi everyone.
I'm Simon Forman, head of
behavioral data engineering
a ITV.
So let's start there.
What's behavioral
data engineering?
Well, it's building
and running the systems
that capture, process,
and leverage data
from our users as they visit
our websites, use our apps,
and watch our shows.
You might think that sounds
like traditional web analytics.
But we actually do a lot
more than that with the data
that we have.
And I'll talk about that later.
So to rewind-- three years ago,
we weren't using GCP at all.
And our analytics
data was in the hands
of a supplier with all the
problems that that can bring.
Then I wrote our first
prototype streaming Dataflow job
and proved that it would work
for our analytics use case.
But then we had to take
a big leap of faith.
Although I'd proved
the system would work,
I couldn't predict how
much it would cost to run
or whether it would scale.
So we took the risk.
And I pushed the change to move
all our analytics data over
to the new system on GCP.
And now I lead the
engineering team
as we do more and more exciting
things with behavioral data.
ITV's the largest
commercial broadcaster
in the UK with
broadcast TV channels
and an online streaming service
used by millions of people
everyday.
Last summer, ITV had
two massive events--
the football World
Cup from Russia
and the return of our
reality TV hit, Love Island.
In the football,
England exceeded
everyone's expectations--
and our audience
size predictions--
reaching the semi-final stage.
That match was watched by 27
million people on our broadcast
channel.
That's the biggest
UK TV audience
since the Olympics in 2012.
And even more impressively,
almost a million people
streamed the match live online,
beating our previous streaming
record many times over.
Love Island also attracted
big audiences every day
of its eight week run, with more
of the young audience choosing
to stream rather than watch
the broadcast channel.
So both events had
lots of viewers.
But the load profiles
were quite different.
Football fans tend
to start watching
during the pregame show, or
even a bit after kickoff,
giving a long ramp up
to the highest audience,
as shown by the blue
line on the graph.
Love Island's a different story.
The show's in a
broadcast slot with drama
from the very first minute,
so fans arrive en masse
just as it starts.
The steep green line
shows just how quickly
the audience goes from zero
to hundreds of thousands
in just a couple of minutes.
These audiences
generate huge amounts
of data for my team's
systems and give us
the challenge of collecting
it all in real time
and scaling our processing
systems to handle it
without slowing down.
I'm going to talk about how we
build and run the systems that
handle that data
on GCP, starting
with our goals for the project.
Now although we run a
video on demand service,
our busiest events are
actually live streaming.
So we had to be ready
for those surges.
That means the collection
system has to scale quickly.
But the rest of it
needs to keep up.
Or we'll have angry consumers
waiting for the data
that they need.
In the near future, we'll
have to handle a lot more data
as people continue to
shift their attention
to online streaming and we
incorporate other data sources.
We want to avoid growing
the team at the same rate.
So we lean heavily on managed
services with low operational
support requirements.
BigQuery and Cloud Functions are
really good examples of this.
We want people to
trust our data--
trust that it's complete
and that it's accurate.
And we want the
front end engineering
teams to have an easy
job of implementing
data reporting for us.
And finally, we want our
downstream consumers,
like data scientists,
to be able to use
the data we share with them
as a foundation for their work
without doing any tedious
cleanup beforehand.
GCP, and especially
Pub/Sub and BigQuery,
make it very easy to deploy
new applications that
use data without any
risk to existing ones.
Now I'm going to show
you some examples of what
our systems actually look like,
starting with the one that
receives data from our users.
All of our apps and
sites have embedded
code that sends small pieces
of data back to simple receiver
services using HDTV.
These services are
either Cloud Functions
or run on Compute Engine.
The one that handles
video playback events has
to be able to cope with
sudden surges from people
watching live events.
So we use sensitively
configured auto scaling
to handle those highs
without spending
a fortune on excess capacity.
This service does
minimal processing
of the events it receives.
The strategy is to get
them onto a Pub/Sub topic
as quickly as possible.
Having everything
go through Pub/Sub
means we can plug-in different
consumers very easily.
In one case, we have 13
consumers for one topic.
On the right of
this diagram there's
a Dataflow job
writing to BigQuery.
This stores everything
in its raw format.
And it's a pattern that
we repeat on most topics,
whether they're dealing with
raw data, like this case,
or aggregated.
Often these are archives
needed for audit purposes.
So we have to store it.
But it's also been very helpful
for debugging or to replay
historical data
through a new job.
We considered file-based storage
for this instead of BigQuery.
But there wasn't much
difference in the cost.
And having the data online in
a way that was easily queried
was a really nice benefit.
Now moving onto a
more complex system,
this diagram shows the flow
of video playback and site
interaction data through
two Dataflow jobs that first
summarize then sessionize it.
Summarizing means turning
possibly hundreds of events
from one video stream
into a single summary
of the important bits--
who the user was, what
show they watched,
how long they watched
it for, and so on.
This job's data source
is the same topic
the ingest service on the
previous slide was pushing to.
Sessionizing is pulling together
all of the video summaries
and site interactions
for each user session
and delivering them
downstream as a bundle.
This job reads summaries
from the summarizers output
topic and raw site interaction
data from another one
and publishes to its
own output topic.
Hanging off the
sessionizers topic
is a Cloud Function that
applies some formatting
before pushing to another topic
that we use as the handoff
to a third party.
This gives them
lots of flexibility
about how they pull that data,
be it streaming, or batch,
or even push.
In this diagram, you can
also see two BigQuery logging
jobs that store all
the video summaries
and the sessionized
data in tables.
And now onto a Dataflow job
that gives us real time quality
of service data.
This data shows us how our video
streaming service is performing
and lets ITV's operations team
quickly jump on any problem.
The job reads raw video playback
events and aggregates them,
then publishes to a topic,
typically with just 30 seconds
of delay between a user having
a problem like re-buffering
and that being reflected
in the output data.
From the topic, we write
to BigQuery for long term
storage and analysis.
And we push the Splunk for
live dashboards and alerting.
And in the last example
of architecture,
I'll show you how the cross
device resume feature works.
This is a product feature
where you can pick up
where you're playing
on a different device,
say going from an
iPhone to a smart TV.
We push a subset of
the same video event
data using a node
JS app into Redis
and expose this to the front end
apps through a Cloud Function.
Latency is absolutely
critical here.
So we're willing to trade
some reliability to reduce it.
We were able to
save a heap of time
and built this feature without
adding any position logging
code to the front end apps by
reusing the data we already had
and building a service to
expose it in a new way.
So that was a look at some of
the things that we've built--
now onto how we run them.
Our internal customers
care about data accuracy.
We replaced an old
analytics system.
And we have to be at least as
good as it was by that measure.
They want data
without any delay so
that they can use it to power
real time product features
and drive operational reporting.
And they want us to quickly
build new applications
and incorporate more data
sources into existing ones.
And to support this,
we have metrics--
SLIs that we watch.
At the ingest stage, we
don't want any errors.
We want to collect all
the data and get it safely
onto a Pub/Sub topic.
And we want that data
to be high quality.
It needs to match the
spec for required fields
and suitable values.
Once we have the data
and it's well-formed,
we need to process it quickly.
And a good way to
check that's happening
is look at the size of the
backlogs on the Pub/Sub
subscriptions we use.
And lastly, saturation--
it's important to make
sure we're not getting
close to any capacity limits
to avoid delaying, or even
worse, losing any data.
Now I'll show you some
of the dashboards that
demonstrate this.
The first one shows how
we monitor the video data
summarizer job.
You can think of this job in
classical input process output
terms.
It pulls messages from a Pub/Sub
subscription-- the input--
applies some business logic--
that's the process-- then
outputs video summaries.
The graphs here show how each
of those stages is behaving.
The two on the far
left show the rate
that data is being
published to the input topic
and how much of
that hasn't yet been
consumed by the Dataflow job.
A backlog here would
indicate the job
not keeping up with
the source data rate,
and consequently
delaying its output.
But the spikes in
the graph here are
short lived, just a
couple of minutes,
and are caused by the job
auto scaling up and down.
So they're not something
to worry about.
In the higher middle
graph, there's
a view of the
Dataflow job's lag,
which is a measure of the oldest
data still being processed.
If this is elevated, output
data will again be delayed.
Below that is what the auto
scaling system is doing.
We want this to roughly move
in line with the input data
volume.
If it isn't, that could be
an indication of a problem--
for example, hitting
the maximum but still
needing more
resources to keep up.
Top right is a custom metric.
We added code to
the Dataflow job
to increment a counter
whenever a condition is hit.
In this case, it's counting
malformed source data--
data that we can't
process, because it doesn't
have all the fields we need.
We want this to stay a low
fraction of the input rate.
If it deviates
from that trend, we
could have a problem
with our data sources.
And lastly, the
lower right graph
shows how many summaries
are being produced--
the final output stage.
A drop here means the
job isn't producing
the data it should be.
Taken together, these graphs
show the job's overall health,
and if there's a problem,
what the likely cause is.
This dashboard looks at
one of our ingest systems--
the part that handles the
fire hose of data coming in
from our apps and sites.
I'm a big fan of the SRE
book's four golden signals--
traffic, latency,
errors, and saturation.
And they're monitored here.
At the top left, there's
a view of the request
rate, split by response code.
Any problems with the service
would show up here as 500s.
There usually aren't any
though, so that hugs the x-axis.
Below that is the
service's latency--
how quickly it's publishing
the piece of data to Pub/Sub
and returning an
OK back to the app.
The apps aren't actually
latency sensitive.
And we're not affecting the user
experience at all by being slow
here.
But increased latency
does drastically
reduce the service's capacity.
So it could turn
into a full outage
if it continues or
becomes more widespread.
The orange, green,
and purple graph
shows the service's
own view of how quickly
Pub/Sub is accepting data,
again taken from the SRE book.
The time each Publish operation
takes is bucketed and counted.
This gives a high
resolution view
without storing and
graphing millions
of data points every minute.
Everything in the
orange region and above
is quicker than
100 milliseconds,
with just a small
number of requests
taking longer than that.
You might see them in the
lower right area of the graph.
And lastly, saturation-- the
two graphs in the top right
are from the auto scaling
group's monitoring.
Obviously, hitting the upper
configured limit is bad.
But we also want to see
the instance count, CPU,
and request rate roughly
moving in sync with each other.
And this last
dashboard shows how
we monitor the data
feed out to our partner.
A Pub/Sub subscription
is the boundary
between our two organizations.
We publish data to it,
and our partner pulls it.
So the key metrics are the
publish rate and the pull rate
on the top row.
If these stay balanced,
we won't get a backlog.
And data won't be delayed.
If a backlog has
grown, the lower two
graphs show how much data
and how many messages
is waiting to be consumed.
The spike in the center of the
graphs was less of a problem
than its shape suggests.
And the backlog was only a
few seconds worth of data.
And it cleared quite quickly.
So that was how we take
care of running systems.
But how do we deploy code
when streaming jobs run 24/7?
Things are a bit
different with streaming.
Updates, and Cloud Functions,
and simple Compute Engine apps
is easy.
There's no state,
so they're naturally
easy to change online.
Dataflow jobs that do hold
state are much harder.
Stopping and starting
isn't an option,
as that would lose some output
data or introduce inaccuracy.
The best solution is to live
update the running job using
Dataflow's built in feature.
This is quick and easy.
In fact, we have
Dataflow jobs that
are updated automatically by our
continuous deployment system.
But it's sometimes not possible
to use this feature if there's
a significant difference
in the job structure
or the code's not compatible.
So we needed a smarter way to
release fixes and improvements
without stopping the job.
Our solution for the
video summarizer process
is to start the updated job
while the old one is still
running.
The new one gets its
own input subscription,
so it'll get a copy of the
same data as the old one.
But having two running
causes a problem.
The new job will also
be emitting data,
at best causing
duplication, or if it
doesn't have the
full state, producing
data that's just incorrect.
We needed a way for
the new job to wait
until it had all the
state it needed before it
started outputting anything.
And we needed the old job
to stop producing data
at exactly the same time so
that there was no duplication.
Synchronizing the two
jobs looked very complex
and couldn't even guarantee
exactly one's output.
So we looked for a way
for them to coordinate
without any direct
communication.
The thing we came up with
was to use a characteristic
of the output data here at the
start time of the video stream
as the deciding factor.
We pick a point in
time and say any data
from before then comes
from the old job,
and anything after that
point comes from the new job.
To implement this, we
added a feature to the job
where it could conditionally
drop data instead of publishing
it to the output topic.
It still reads all the source
data, applies the same logic--
it just doesn't
publish the result.
So let's go through the
whole deployment process.
To start with, the old
version is running.
That's the green line.
And it's emitting data to the
output topic, the green boxes.
Then we deploy the new
version, the blue line,
and a specify a cut-over time
some hours in the future.
And we reconfigure the old job
with the same cut-over time.
We'll be able to see metrics
from the new job showing
that it's working as expected.
But if it isn't, we can just
stop it and look into why.
When data is produced for
after the cut-over time,
it'll come from the new job.
That's the blue
boxes on the diagram.
After a while, the old job
won't be producing anything.
So we can stop it and
clear up its subscription.
So that's a quick tour
of our current work.
What about the future?
So we already support
personalization features
across our apps.
And we're going to
build even more of them,
often using the same
data we already have.
We're working on ad tech to help
our commercial teams deliver
more value to our advertisers.
Our platform provides a
way for data scientists
to quickly and easily put
their research into production
and work on challenges
like improving marketing
effectiveness and better
understanding our audiences
and how do they use our
products to increase engagement.
And thanks to the
capacity we have,
we can begin to collect data
from our enormous broadcast
audiences, gaining extra
insight into our viewers.
So to reflect on
what we've achieved,
we provide high quality data.
Quality is embedded
throughout the pipeline
from how we build our front
end apps through validating
the data we receive to checking
that what we're producing
is correct.
Our data is trusted by
the people who use it.
They know it's accurate.
And they happily rely on it.
It's available immediately.
Our streaming jobs deliver
useful process data
without any delay.
And we support real time
personalization features.
Last summer, we had
more online viewers
and successfully
collected many times
more data than ever before
while maintaining our latency
and reliability SLOs.
And we did that without
any re-engineering.
This gives us
confidence to handle
the next tenfold increase as
more people move their viewing
online and we begin to collect
data from broadcast services.
What started as an experiment
with one Dataflow job
has turned into a mature
data platform that
supports analytics, operations,
and front end product features
and sets us up for a future
of more and more data
based applications.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
Back to you, Kir.
KIR TITIEVSKY: Thanks, Simon.
All right, we're almost there.
So I hope this gave you
sort of a flavor of what
that shift to
streaming looks like.
Yes, it's a shift.
You have to do a little bit
of work in both how you think
and how you organize your
systems and engineering.
But perhaps this makes
it more familiar.
We also hope that this idea
of Stream Analytics being
core to your quality
of service data
is an interesting
reason to take back
to your job and sort of feel
empowered to not just implement
new features and move data from
databases to databases, which
is absolutely
critical, but also do
something that is sort
of fundamental to what
your company does.
So clearly, there's
a lot more than that
that you can do
with real time data.
But that's just one reason.
Before we part, I wanted to--
or rather, before
we shift to Q&A,
I wanted to touch on
a couple of things--
so a few features
that have to do
with running Stream Analytics
pipelines in real life
that have come out in recent
time-- in sort of recent months
that I wanted to highlight,
as well as a few more sessions
that will go deeper into some of
the some aspects of this topic
that we haven't gotten
a chance to touch on.
So the first is the newer
features in Cloud Pub/Sub--
what's very important for
operating these systems
is the ability to replay data
to recover from problems.
If that's not possible,
you are now also
able to discard messages
or events in bulk.
Also look out for
upcoming controls
on where data is stored in
this global service as well
as new ways of
optimizing costs where
we've split off egress
data and local usage data.
On Dataflow, stream engine--
streaming engine, which
has hit GA recently,
is a very interesting
thing in that
it offloads a lot of the state
away from individual processing
nodes, which makes them more
disposable, and so stable,
and also much more flexible
in terms of optimization.
So streaming auto scaling now
works much more granularly.
And, of course, in real
life, not everybody
loves Java, which is Dataflow's
primary, or first language.
So Python streaming is
now in beta for Dataflow.
And if you stick
around the conference,
there may be a
couple more languages
that we would be announcing.
So speaking of that, here's
some sessions you might hit.
I know they say that
these are booked.
But as you can see, there's
always a seat you could find.
And also, there'll
be videos and slides.
Slides, I'm pretty sure, are
posted after the conference.
So in particular, I would
to highlight the Thursday
sections, because the titles
are a bit nondescript.
The 11:40 session,
DA311, is going to dive
into Dataflow and sort of
what's happening there.
It's going to be a
reasonably deep session.
And 2:35 on Thursday, GCP
for Apache Kafka users
is going to cover this topic
from the perspective of not
using necessarily
our native tools
but looking at Kafka as
sort of a common departure
point for this.
With that, that's
all our content.
I think you get a
chance to rate us.
The way you do this
is you open the app,
and you find the fifth
star, and you press on it.
If you don't feel that you
can do that and maintain
your integrity, come
yell at us in person.
We love hearing feedback.
[MUSIC PLAYING]